- All right everybody,
we have time for one more uplifting story.
This is "#What I'm Liking"
(upbeat music)
So, this month, the "Miss America" pageant
made history when, for
the very first time,
they crowned an active-duty
military officer as the winner.
22-year-old second
lieutenant, Madison Marsh,
isn't just a pilot, but that's so cool,
she's also a graduate
student at Harvard, sure.
And check out her interview
just before she won the pageant.
- [Interviewer] So, as Miss
America, it says that you want
to go on "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
So, let's pretend, you're
walking out as Miss America,
"Kelly Clarkson Show,"
What is your message as Miss America
to all of those young girls out there?
- They can do anything that they want.
They can be Miss America,
they can be a military member,
they can be a doctor, lawyer, you name it.
And I think me being able
to be there echoes that
to women all around the world.
And that's exactly what I wanna do
and capitalize on in my international plan
with the Air Force.
- I mean, I love the girl!
I'm also honored to help
her spread her message.
Let's welcome your 2024 "Miss America"
Second Lieutenant, Madison Marsh!
(audience applauding)
♪ There she is, Miss America ♪
- This is so crazy!
- It is amazing, look at
what you've accomplished,
that nobody else has.
- First of all, thank you
so much for your service.
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
I mean this, you think this
is more than a win for you though, right?
- Absolutely, I mean, I kind
of talked about a little bit
how it goes more than just me winning
and how I feel like I get
to represent all women.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Women in the military
being able to show,
like, we can break boundaries,
and that femininity can be a
superpower and you use that
to be a leader and they
don't have to be separated
- [Kelly] Separate, because
I think people do that.
You're either this or
that and you can be both.
I love that message.
- Yeah.
So there was a very
important thing for you
to be honoring your mom through
this whole process, right?
- [Madison] Mm hm.
So, I lost my mom to
pancreatic cancer in 2018,
She was only 41 years
old and was misdiagnosed.
And we had no cancer
history in our family,
she didn't have any of the warning signs.
And so, when she passed
away, I saw how much
she would've given to
be here to have her life
and her love shared with everyone.
And I know that I have an
incredible opportunity every day.
Each day that I get is an
opportunity that my mom
and other pancreatic cancer
patients didn't have,
so that's why we started the Whitney,
- It's a privilege.
- Yeah.
So that's why we started that
Whitney Marsh Foundation.
So basically we raise money
for pancreatic cancer care,
advocacy and the patients.
We do a 5K, 10K every year for my mom
'cause she's a big runner.
I mean, when she was going
through chemotherapy,
that woman was running 10 miles.
- Oh my gosh.
- So, yeah.
- What a superhero mom.
- I know, I know.
- Yeah, That's incredible.
Thank you so much for being
just such a powerful influence
for young women and young men.
Like, anybody can do
anything they wanna do.
You can achieve it, it's
just such a cool thing.
And what a barrier to break
that nobody even really,
maybe, realized was there.
But, like, yeah, you can be both things.
You can be beautiful and
powerful, and you represent that.
So thank you for doing that.
- Thank you.
- Yes, there's so many young people.
Thank you Madison, I'm
liking your post right now.
That is not all though.
Our season long partner
Pilot, pen makers of Precise,
the Go-To pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable people
just like you and your mama.
So they are gonna be writing
the Whitney Marsh Foundation
a check for $1,000, just so you know.
- Oh my.
- Thank you so much,
you are so incredible.
- Thank you for having me.
- Come back any time!
- Oh, thank you so much.
- Yeah!
Thank you to all of our guests this hour,
Chrissy Teigen, David
Chang, Bianca Belair,
Montez Ford and Rachel Montez Minor.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, change it.